non-minimalists
my biggest question is books i love
books so much i really don't have a lot
of books but the books that i do
have i really love art in our garage
because
our apartment is too small to
have a bookcase and share all the books
with everybody but i really do love them
um i'm just knowing that my husband is
gonna want me to get rid of them
so that is my question is what should we
do with those
so nicole yeah yes this is
a problem for for several reasons i'll
talk to you about how i i
use well how i store my own books how
i've tackled this problem in my own life
but sean podcast john do you have any
advice for nicole
yeah i said uh get rid of the husband
and keep the books
well hopefully he's not going to give
you that that ultimatum right
uh and you said he wants you to get rid
of the books and i think the reason
being is not that he doesn't want you to
have joy
from your books it's they're taking up a
lot of space in
your shared space and so what my wife
and i have done together is we have two
small bookshelves if you go to our home
tour which you can find on the resources
page of theminimalists.com
the minimalist.com resources you can see
a home tour
me and my wife have two book shelves
there
and once those book shelves are filled
up
we could very easily buy more
bookshelves or i guess we could we don't
have a garage but we have a
we our building has a a small garage and
we have this tiny little storage space
in that garage area that could fit some
books i could cram it full of books
but why would i do that now i want to
talk to you nicole about
the way you're talking about your books
and i think if you're trying to let go
of the attachment with these books
you said you love them so much
and that indicates to me that i haven't
done a very good job
of teaching you to love people and use
things there's nothing wrong with
enjoying the experience of books in fact
i really encourage you to do that i
think books can do some things that
other mediums like film or even music
can't do and so i'm a big
fan of books and i think that's what you
mean i really do think that's what you
mean i don't think you mean you love
them
i think we have a language problem right
because you can say
i love tacos but i also love my
husband wow what does that mean does it
mean the same thing
that it's a difficult decision but
choosing between the two
no well hopefully you don't have to
choose between tacos and your husband or
books
and your husband but you do need to form
some sort of daytaunt in your household
and that means setting up some limits
because otherwise we don't have limits
we can let everything in
if everything is precious to us then
nothing
is precious to us you could tweet that
podcast sean
now i would love for you to start
changing your language around books
i don't want you to be less excited i
want you to pick up this book
the answers by katherine lacy which i
could tell you i think a few years ago i
would have said
i love this book because it's such a
great
experience i dive into the consciousness
of the author of the characters
it's an amazing book but what i really
mean is
man i enjoy this book and there are
times where
there's nothing i would rather do than
explore
the pages the world within this book
there was a writer i think it was rick
moody i heard him talk about
why he chose to be a writer someone in
an interview asked him
hey you know there's all these other
things you can do you could be a yoga
instructor
you could be an astronaut you could be
a hunter you could be a school
teacher you could be an accountant
you could be a detective you could be
a trash collector why are you a writer
why didn't you decide to be one of these
things and he thought about it for a
moment
paused and said i guess
i decided to be a writer because it's
the only
profession in which i could be all of
those things
i can be the trash collector and the
yoga instructor
and the detective i could be anything i
want if i'm a writer and i think the
same is true
when we really get lost in the book as a
reader i can
take on the life of those characters a
great writer
is not making the story with the reader
they're the dictator of their own world
they've created this world for you
and it's a beautiful world it's a sad
world it's an elated world it's an
exciting world it's a terrifying world
depending on how the author sets that up
and i want to get lost in books it
sounds like you do too
but right now you're lost in them
physically they're stacked all around
you
but you maybe you're not getting the
value from them you actually could
of course i'm not telling you to get rid
of all of your books but maybe there's
some sort of limitation that you and
your husband can agree on
for me that's two bookshelves that hold
about 40 books each
so i guess that means we probably have
about 80 books at home but anytime
one of us brings home a new book from
our local bookstore
or if we order one online we have to get
rid of a book that's on there because i
don't have any more room
and it'd be silly for me to just keep
adding to the piles
more and more and more it allows me to
think about a book before i bring it
into my life but also
i don't treat any of them as precious
i'm willing to let any of them go and
especially
if it's a book i get a lot of joy from
those are the books i let go
most fervently because i want other
people to get joy from those
as well so if after this jordan were to
come up to me
and he were to say hey man i really you
know i've been thinking about writing a
memoir and
i see you've got this book by mary carr
it's called the art of memoir
can i read that i said yeah have it i
want you to get value from it
i care about jordan and i know that one
of the ways to add value to his life
is to contribute to him in some way and
if i think this would add value to his
life and it's not a
giving a gift but in a way it is gift
giving
it's it's a way to add value to someone
else's life so be willing
to let go of these especially if they're
no longer adding value to you
because if they're no longer adding
value to you then one of the
kindest most compassionate things you
can do for the people around you
is let go of them so someone else can
get value
from those books speaking of books
nicole i'm going to send you a copy
of one of our books that might might
sound uh
cruel at this point that i'm sending you
a book and you're dealing with a
collection of books so
maybe instead of the print book which i
have here it's my favorite book that
we've ever written it's called
everything that remains
it's a five-year journey of me and ryan
being the suit and tie corporate guys to
becoming
the minimalists and one of my favorite
openings of anything that we've written
i'll read a little bit from
the the opening of everything that
remains
this is the first chapter called
fluorescent ghosts
our identities are shaped by the
costumes we wear
i'm seated in a cramped conference room
surrounded by ghosts and shirt sleeves
and pleated trousers
there are 35 maybe 40 people here middle
managers the lot of us
mostly caucasian mostly male all
oozing apathy the group's median
complexion
is that of an agoraphobe a microsoft
excel spreadsheet is projected onto an
oversized canvas pulled from the ceiling
at the front of the room the canvas is
flimsy and cracked and is a shade of
off-white that suggests it's a relic
from a time when employees were allowed
to smoke indoors
the rest of the room is aggressively
white
the walls are white the ceiling is white
the people are white as if all cut from
the same materials
well everyone except stan seated at the
back of the room
i'll pause it there but i hope you
enjoyed this copy of everything that
remains if you like
our podcast i think you really enjoy the
audiobook version and that
won't add to your book clutter or if you
want the ebook version we're happy to
send that to you
as well nicole